The Joe Rogan Experience well people are
tweeting like they're from Bud Light now
because uh you know there's there's Bud
Light if you go Bud Light underscore so
they're making these like very subtle
commercials they're like almost is like
nothing goes with wieners like Bud Light
wow you know and it's like two hot dogs
I didn't realize we were like what is
this what is a parody account and then
it is a parody yeah but it's it's subtle
I didn't realize that that uh
that like what's it called
um you know
them people abandoning it would be that
driven like it's crazy it really has
stuck and and they there was a I saw an
article about Revenue
and like and and the the share that they
have of the market and how it has
totally taken a shift like 26 billion
dollars it's crazy yeah they really
really did boy that's the word I was
looking for they were boycotting it yeah
and then
the trans movement got mad that they
didn't support Dylan Mulvaney so a lot
of like LBGTQ and whatever the other
letters are those bars stop carrying Bud
Light so it's because they felt like Bud
Light didn't back them up and then there
was video footage of them sponsoring a
pride parade
so it's like a Bud Light Parade truck
with a bunch of people dancing around
like we like to [__] guys too you know
I'm a girl yeah I like to [__] girls
like whatever it is it's like they're
like dancing around inside this yeah so
now they're advertising in front of the
pride people and so then the people are
like oh they're [__] doubling down
it's like they can't win no so the pride
people are mad how weird is it when you
say Pride people immediately think of
Gay Pride means gay yeah how Wild is
that yeah that they did that yeah they
own like it's it's Kane Velasquez has
brown pride tattooed on his chest yeah
now people like what are you trying to
say he's gay Brown what's that what are
you trying to say you know it used to be
you were proud right now now it's gay
it's me it definitely means wild queer
pride month queer month I'm imagine you
don't even have to say gay pride anymore
yeah you say pride month how Insidious
they snuck it in they slowly took over
Pride like they took over the rainbow
it's yeah the Rainbows are that is
it's so funny to think that University
of Hawaii used to have rainbows on their
helmets can't have it anymore well
they're also too beautiful I think the
football team was like can we get
something like it was not even related
to gay they were like shouldn't we be
the tiger shark yes like give us and
they finally changed it what do they
know well I forget what the but they
they put a like a more badass design on
the helmets but for years it was a
rainbow you know because it was like
Hawaii you know it was supposed to be
and they were like come on man we're
supposed to be at the yeah that was on
the side of a helmet now it's the at
like on the bottom it's like that H you
know isn't that crazy though the the
rainbow has become
I mean it it's a it's gay Rainbow's a
gay thing remember they're gay yeah yeah
I mean that's what it is now pride is
it's a gay thing the word is like if you
say you have straight Pride people like
really yeah of course do you really do
you really yeah you should first of all
why yeah if you're 99 of the people
yeah [__] you Prada like they had a
pride a straight pride parade and I was
like if I was a gay guy trying to [__] a
guy in the closet that's where I would
go I go that's trade Pride praying see
who's yelling the loudest let me see who
I can get over here yeah you want to
argue
this is such a weird time man such a
weird time because unfortunately because
of social media now anything that you do
you can you can form an identity around
it and then it can be like your identity
in terms of like your source of like how
you view yourself in the world you no
longer view yourself in the world as
just a human being that's just accepted
for whatever you're interested in now
you're in like a very specific category
or group and then there's other people
in that group and you you think there's
people that are opposed to you and there
are people that are post them yeah so
then then you're in Conflict now you're
part of a gang you know it's going to go
after those people that are against us
[__] them
it's wild yeah it's exhausting too
exhausting exhausting
and people want to fight they want to
argue about [__] don't you just feel
like I mean like I don't I get such
mental um fatigue from a lot of this
stuff but I just feel like I'm an
observer and I kind of put it to the
side and go I I just I can't you can't
entertain and ingest every one of these
things going on well that's the if
you're a conspiracy theorist yeah this
is this is the real conspiracy the
conspiracy is have as many social
problems as possible people destroy get
distracted by the people concentrate on
whether it's a pandemic whether it's
masks vaccines
Pride trans movement drag sponsor drag
shows for kids if you want people to get
mad and want people to get distracted
right right sponsor them focus on that
get people to think that it's a good
idea to do that and and watch watch the
outrage you know get people to think
that the ocean is going to be boiling in
five years you know right get get people
think that if we don't change it like
that was one of the things that Greta
Thornburg said five years ago that we'll
all be dead okay five years well it's
five years later yeah and we're not all
dead so you're definitely are wrong and
you're 16. so why are they flying you
out to Ukraine like what's going on so
there's these so many of these [__]
social distractions that are in our face
all day long about everything and I feel
like sometimes that's what I feel like
about Supreme Court rulings we're going
to take away Roe v Wade and everybody's
like what the [__] what yeah what and
that's another one and then that one
becomes a thing that people identify as
the most important problem that they
have to solve and while all this is
going on money's getting moved around
decisions are getting made yeah and it's
a brilliant cover for wild [__] yeah
because all you have to do ever really
is a is follow the money on anything
yeah and you see what's actually
happening and everything else is a
distraction to that